Mediante la fermentación de granos,
materia vegetal y productos animales,
los pueblos y las culturas del mundo han domesticado a los microorganismos
para transformar lo no comestible en comestible.
Incluso existen evidencias de que ya en el año 350 d. C.
la gente fermentaba deliberadamente los alimentos que contenían antibióticos.
Se descubrió que los restos óseos de algunos nubios de Sudán
contenían importantes depósitos de tetraciclina,
un antibiótico que se usa en la medicina moderna.
Y casi 1500 años después,
Alexander Fleming descubrió las propiedades antimicrobianas del moho.
Y fue con la fermentación industrializada de la penicilina
que millones de personas pudieron sobrevivir a enfermedades infecciosas.
Nuevamente, la fermentación podría desempeñar un importante rol
en el desarrollo humano.
¿Podría representar una nueva forma de supervivencia
si la utilizamos para cambiar las industrias de manera radical?
La faceta creativa de mi trabajo me ha permitido desarrollar
nuevos materiales para la industria textil.
Y si bien es una tarea que me encanta,
no logro reconciliarme con el hecho de que la industria textil
es una de las más contaminantes del mundo.
La mayor parte del daño ecológico causado por el procesamiento textil
ocurre en la etapa final de tintura.
El procesamiento textil requiere enormes cantidades de agua.
Y debido a que la era del petróleo transformó la industria textil
de manera radical,
gran parte de los materiales y químicos utilizados para procesarlos
derivan del petróleo.
Y esto, sumado a nuestro apetito insaciable por la moda efímera,
se arroja a los vertederos de basura
una inmensa cantidad de desechos textiles cada año,
porque sigue siendo sumamente difícil reciclarlos.
Nuevamente, comparémoslo con la biología,
que evolucionó a lo largo de más de 3800 millones de años
para hacer un prototipo rápido
de reciclado y reabastecimiento
mejor que cualquier sistema que hayamos desarrollado.
Inspirada en este inmenso potencial,
decidí explorarlo partiendo de una pregunta aparentemente simple
-- en aquel momento.
Si una bacteria produce un pigmento,
¿cómo podemos usarlo para teñir productos textiles?
Una de mis técnicas favoritas
es cultivar el Streptomyces coelicolor directamente en la seda.
Vemos aquí cómo cada colonia produce pigmento en su territorio circundante.
Pero si agregamos muchísimas células,
producen tal cantidad de tintura como para saturar toda la tela.
Ahora bien, lo mágico de esta técnica de tintura
-- esta especie de fermentación directa
cuando se incorporan bacterias directamente sobre la seda --
es que para teñir una camiseta
las bacterias sobreviven en solo 200 ml de agua.
Y vemos que este proceso genera muy poco desperdicio de agua
y produce un pigmento de color inalterable sin el uso de químicos.
Estarán pensando ahora
-- y con razón --
que un problema inherente al diseño de un sistema vivo es:
¿cómo hacemos para controlar un medio que tiene vida propia?
Pues bien, una vez establecida la línea de base
para que el cultivo de Streptomyces
produzca suficiente cantidad de pigmento de manera regular,
podemos recurrir a maniobras tales como
retorcer, doblar, sujetar, mojar, rociar, sumergir.
Todo esto empieza a definir la estética de la actividad del coelicolor.
Y si se usa de manera sistemática
podremos producir un diseño orgánico,
una tintura uniforme,
e incluso un estampado gráfico.
Otro problema es cómo adaptar estos métodos artesanales
para poder usarlos a escala industrial.
Cuando hablamos de escala,
debemos considerar dos aspectos en paralelo:
cómo ajustar la biología a escala,
y cómo ajustar las herramientas y los procesos
necesarios para trabajar con la biología.
Si logramos hacerlo trasladando el procedimiento
a una placa de Petri
para ponerlo a escala humana,
y luego, con suerte, a la arquitectura de nuestro medio ambiente.
Si Fleming viviera
estos serían, sin dudas, algunos de sus instrumentos de trabajo.
Vemos aquí la aproximación más aceptable que hemos logrado
para ajustar la biología a escala.
Es un biorreactor,
una especie de cervecería de microorganismos
que contiene levaduras
que han sido desarrolladas para producir químicos y compuestos específicos,
como fragancias y sabores.
Está conectado a un red de hardware y software automatizados
que leen en tiempo real e informan a un equipo de diseñadores
sobre las condiciones de crecimiento de los microbios.
Este sistema, entonces, puede ser usado
para emular las características de crecimiento
de un organismo como el coelicolor
y ver cómo fermentaría en 50 000 litros.
Actualmente trabajo en Ginkgo Bioworks,
un nuevo emprendimiento biotecnológico en Boston.
Allí estoy investigando
la manera en que la plataforma de ajuste a escala de la biología
puede interactuar
con mis métodos artesanales de diseño textil con bacterias.
Estamos trabajando con el Streptomyces coelicolor
para que produzca más pigmento.
También estamos considerando el uso de instrumentos
específicamente diseñados para automatizar la biología sintética,
con la idea de adaptarlos para estampar y teñir productos textiles.
También estoy usando la fabricación digital,
porque los instrumentos que necesito
para trabajar con el coelicolor en realidad no existen.
De manera que, en este caso,
-- en la última semana, en realidad --
diseñé una placa de Petri
pensada para producir un estampado personalizado sobre una prenda completa.
Estamos haciendo kimonos en cantidad.
Lo interesante de todo esto
es que no estoy sola.
Hay otros que están especializándose en el sector,
como MycoWorks.
MycoWorks es una empresa nueva
cuyo objetivo es reemplazar cuero animal por cuero fabricado a partir de hongos
un material versátil, de excelente rendimiento,
que ofrece aplicaciones fuera de la industria textil,
como en la fabricación de productos y en el sector de arquitectura.
Y Bolt Threads
desarrolló una levadura que produce una proteína de la seda de araña
capaz de fabricar un hilo altamente programable.
Pensemos en impermeabilidad,
elasticidad y alta resistencia.
Para poder lograr economías a escala,
este tipo de empresas se ven obligadas a construir, diseñar y desarrollar
la infraestructura para poder trabajar con la biología.
Por ejemplo,
Bolt Threads tuvo que recurrir a un caso de imitación biológica extrema.
Para poder hilar el producto que esta levadura transforma en hebras,
han desarrollado una máquina para fabricas hebras
capaz de imitar las condiciones fisiológicas
en que las arañas normalmente tejen su propia seda.
Esto demuestra cuán imaginativas e inspiradoras
son las técnicas creadoras de la naturaleza
y que nosotros podemos usar para desarrollar capacidades
en las nuevas industrias biológicas.
Lo que hoy tenemos es la tecnología
para diseñar, construir, evaluar y ajustar a escala esas capacidades.
En este momento, frente a la crisis ecológica,
debemos decidir
la manera de crear estos nuevos sistemas de materiales
para que no repitan los efectos nefastos de la era del petróleo.
Debemos decidir cómo distribuir esos sistemas
para asegurar un desarrollo sustentable justo e igualitario en todo el mundo.
Y, fundamentalmente, debemos decidir cómo quisiéramos
que las normas legales y éticas de estas tecnologías
interactúen con nuestra sociedad.
La biotecnología tocará todos los aspectos de nuestra vida.
Está viva,
es digital,
está diseñada, y puede ser usada para crear.
Este es el futuro material que necesita de nuestro coraje para poder construirse.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)